enlève ta veste ma veste enlève ta veste
je te dis mais écoutez je comprends pas
enfin et ça qu'est-ce que c'est ça hein
ah bah ah bah ça ça je sais pas je sais
pas je sais pas tu sais pas ce que c'est
ça ah bah ça y était pas ce matin ça des
petites omelettes au fromage de chez
grandvier ça pousse l'après-midi
peut-être peut-être ça je sais pas ça y
était pas comprends pas la recette de la
mer Poulard bravo et ça ça rase un
beurre ben grand jeu dis donc écoutez je
vais vous expliquer enlève tes
chaussures chaussures
ouais c'est sûrement la filière bretonne
à tous les coups là arr tes
chaussures c'est la brandade de maudim
chef elle a sûrement été retraité à
pontaven écoutez je vous assure que
j'étais pas au courantéit bon mon vieux
tu viens pour 20 ans mais non mais
écoutez c'est un malentendu on cherche
à de gens qui veulent du mal
c'est